okay
hello
questions
exactly
i don't have one
oh
uh
do you know what you want to watch this
sunday night
oh no i mean dude
we've been we've been only
earlier than that
oh this is today
two minute warning on the best briefing
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
um
where you all go
sorry
small straw
hi everyone so much green so much green
all right um we today we are fortunate
to have joining us uh secretary of
education
dr miguel cardona who was confirmed just
two weeks ago
a fellow nutmegger that means from
connecticut for any of you who don't
know
he previously served as the commissioner
of education in connecticut
in this position he faced the
unprecedented challenge of responding to
the covet 19 pandemic
and led the safe school reopening
efforts in connecticut
to do so secretary cardona and his
department provided school districts
with the balance of guidance local
autonomy
and oversight needed to ensure equitable
and meaningful
educational opportunities for students
while also prioritizing public health
mitigation measures since he's our fir
it's his first time here first of many
hopefully
uh he has two decades of experience as a
public school educator
he began his uh career as a as an
elementary
school teacher he then served as a
school principal uh so with that i will
turn it over to the secretary
he has a short timeline so he'll be able
to take just a couple questions today um
as always i'll be the bed cop but we'll
turn thank you thank you
good afternoon um as jen mentioned i'm
miguel cardona
we're at a critically important time in
our nation's history in education
and i'm honored to serve as the
secretary of education my goal
my my priority right now is to safely
reopen as many schools as possible
as quickly as possible and to do to do
that
today earlier today i notified all 50
states dc and puerto rico
of the amount of funds they'll be
receiving from the american rescue plan
totaling nearly 122 billion to help them
reopen safely and quickly i'm also
pleased to share that hhs is allocating
an additional 10 billion dollars for
states
to do screening and surveillance testing
of in schools to make sure we can
not only open our schools but keep them
open
and then thirdly i'm really really
excited to announce that next week we
will be having our
national uh reopening summit
for schools where we're going to hear
best practices from across the country
on how to do this safely and how to do
it quickly
because we know there are great examples
out there we know uh
students learn bet from students
teachers learn best from teachers and
states will learn best from states on
how to safely reopen schools quickly
i'm really excited that dr jill biden
will be offering
opening remarks and uh dr rochelle
wallansky will also be in attendance
so i'm excited about that you know as a
parent and as an educator
i know the value of in-person learning
and for those of you that are parents
here you know
there's no substitute for in-person
learning so i'm excited to get the work
get to work uh making sure we can safely
reopen our schools
as quickly as possible i'll take any
questions you have thank you
okay darlene thank you mr secretary
thank you for being here
um you talked about the money that you
uh informed states that they're getting
how will you ensure that the money is
actually spent
for the things that schools need to
reopen it's a great question thank you
it's critically important that we use
the funds to support our students
especially those students who have
had gaps exacerbated as a result of this
pandemic we know
achievement and opportunity gaps have
widened so it's critically important
that
that process is not only communicated
with the with the
education department but publicly as
well we will be uh receiving
reports from the states on how they're
going to be using their money and we
also expect those reports to be public
mr secretary thank you for being here
now that teachers are eligible in most
every state what do you say to those
teachers and school officials
who refuse to get vaccinated
well you know the vaccination is one of
those strategies that we know in
addition to the mitigation strategies
allow for schools to safely reopen so
it's critically important that
we vaccinate as many as possible and we
promote the benefits of
the vaccination to make sure we have
safe school communities
so the message really is if if you're
able
to get a shot get a shot and you know
that's a strategy to help keep our
schools open
nothing about making a mandatory if
teachers want to come back on vaccine
that's fine by you
at this point vaccination is available
for educators i'm proud that the
president prioritize educators
to be vaccinated because we know that
when that's not the case it's more
likely that schools will close due to
quarantining can i ask you about the
money quickly
we know that you said 122 billion
dollars will be given to the states
uh from the american rescue plan right
now the cbo anticipated
that the bulk of the spending of funds
provided through that plan won't be
provided until
after 2021 that there was i think 67
billion dollars that existed from the
past relief
plans that have been passed that
according to the cbo the bulk of which
had not been spent
so why is that accurate and why hasn't
more of that money been spent right now
even before the american rescue plan
money was sent out
to get those schools to safely reopen we
know that uh
the bulk of the money is also being used
on human resources and that's paid out
as
people perform the service or are hired
in their contracts are
paid out and services also are paid when
they're
um given and we're in march we still
have some of the school year left
we're looking to release funds uh this
month
and we know that schools are needing
that to not only prepare for reopening
now but also to plan ahead
we know that when our students come back
they're going to need more social
emotional support
we know that our schools have to be
designed to meet the needs of the
students
after they return after a pandemic so
this is a long-term process also that
they
can plan for next year and the following
year as well with this american rescue
plan
announced 12 billion dollars to help
ramp up testing
in schools how soon people are actually
going to see some of this surveillance
yes that's uh 10 billion dollars from
the health and uh
human services department so we're
looking to get that soon we know that
that's a
tool to help keep schools open not only
reopen but keep them open
uh in the near future the goal really is
this
spring we want our students back in
school uh as quickly as safely as
possible and that's gonna assist in that
process
and we're more than halfway obviously
through march do you have any kind of
update on the administration's effort to
try and get every teacher at least one
shot by the end of the month where that
stands
you know i'm really pleased that at the
state level they recognize many states
recognize the importance of
vaccinating educators not only teachers
but para educators
custodians bus drivers they're
critically important parts of that
school community so
we know that that's a priority in
different states and i think it's as i
said earlier it's part of the strategy
to make sure that our schools are safely
reopened
in addition to those mitigation
strategies that we know when working we
can
also use to safely reopen our schools
we'll bring them back thank you and
thank you thank you
today the head of the cdc said that they
are
looking to update guidance reducing the
social distancing recommendations from
six feet
to three feet this was one of the
stickiest
sticking points for so many schools as
they tried to reopen are you at all
frustrated by this potential course
correction
not at all listen we're in the middle of
a pandemic and i i know the success
we've had in connecticut when i was
commissioner of education
was because we work very closely with
our health department and we we
recognize this is a health pandemic and
we're always going to take guidance
from our health experts our sister
agencies that are health experts so
i recognize it's it may change
and if it does we're going to be able to
adapt and work with them
we were successful because we work
closely with them and we recognize that
uh
you know that partnership is what's
going to lead to our schools being open
as quickly as possible
thank you to three feet would it make it
much easier for schools to reopen in
your opinion
if it does uh go to three feet it'll
provide more opportunities
uh potentially for students to enter our
schools
say something about the shootings in
atlanta
so the president has spoken out very
strongly about the need to
help violence against asian americans
you know as a
education secretary do you see some role
for the
federal government to play in terms of
spreading the message of tolerance or
or you know to work against
discrimination my condolences to the
family and the communities
that suffer that violence in education
we have a lot of work to do
we have to reopen our schools and we
also have to make sure that we're
preparing our students for
a tomorrow that we want for our students
so thank you thank you mr secretary
thank you all right thank you okay um
thank you thank you so much all right a
couple of other things at the top
um i wanted to make sure that you all
saw the announcement uh this afternoon
from the treasury department that as of
today
they've disbursed approximately 90
million economic impact payments which
of course the checks but most of which
are going through
direct deposit totaling more than 242
billion dollars
following last week's signing of the
rescue plan this is a key down payment
toward the president's announcement on
monday
that a hundred million payments would be
sent in ten
days so we'll have we'll continue to
update you as we progress
uh then um the violence against women's
women act as you all know
is being uh considered uh in congress
today uh
he uh it is one of the pres the original
fasting i should say is one of the
president's proudest accomplishments
uh the president applauds the house of
representatives which will vote today
to pass the violence against women
reauthorization act of 2021
with bipartisan expected bipartisan
support and with important improvements
to increase safety and service
services for all survivors reauthorizing
vawa is a priority for the president
and he urges the senate to also come
together in a bi partisan manner
to ensure swift passage of vawa so that
he can sign it into law
soon with that darlene go ahead thank
you jenny
uh first question is there any reaction
from the white house to russia recalling
its ambassador to the u.s they didn't
give a specific
reason for that move but it comes after
a number of russia related developments
uh well we've certainly seen those
reports um
i would say that um you know the uh
our administration is going to take a
different approach in our relationship
to russia than the prior administration
obviously the president spoke
to this during an interview that he
conducted just last night
and we are going to be straightforward
and we are going to be direct in areas
where we have concerns
as you know there is an ongoing review
and the president has well we have
announced key conclusions from an
intelligence community assessment
on the poisoning of alexey novollani we
have there's an ongoing review of other
areas where we have ongoing concerns
at the same time we have areas where we
believe we can work together obviously
the signing of new start is an example
of that
addressing nuclear proliferation is an
example of that
and we we hope that there is opportunity
there but
our relationship will look different we
will be direct
we will speak out on areas where we have
concerns
and it will certainly be uh and as the
president said last night
uh certainly the russians will be held
accountable for
the actions that they have taken we'll
have more on that soon
since you mentioned the interview last
night uh the president was
asked whether the vice president is the
last person in the room with him before
decisions and he responded that most of
the time yes as a practical matter
yeah she is and what then he went on to
say for
for for the full context of the
interview that she's traveling around
the country and reference the fact that
she
uh yesterday was in denver colorado the
day before was in las vegas nevada that
she has been out there
working her heart out uh communicating
with the american people so obviously
when she's on the road she's not
the person always last in the room uh by
practicality uh but
otherwise uh she she certainly is thanks
go ahead uh a question about the
situation on the border
it's now been three weeks since i think
in this room you were first asked about
uh getting us some some press access why
have we still not seen any images
inside these facilities we remain
committed to doing that and i think uh
these facilities are overseen hhs of
course overseen
overseas the shelters uh the dhs
oversees the border patrol facilities
and
we want to work with them to ensure we
can do respecting the privacy
and obviously the health protocols
required by covid but even given coveted
protocols and obviously privacy concerns
you know even you all haven't released
any images that you obviously
could redact if you wanted to again we
we remain committed to
sharing with all of you uh data on the
number of kids crossing
the border the steps we're taking the
work we're doing to open up facilities
uh
our own bar we're setting for ourselves
and improving
the and expediting the timeline and uh
the uh the treatment of of these
children and we remain committed to
transparency i don't have an update for
you on the timeline for
access but it's certainly something we
support
we're hearing from border agents that
they're frustrated that they can't
show us what's actually happening along
the border they can't do ride-alongs
they can't answer questions
about what's happening inside certainly
seems like there's an element of secrecy
here
why i i certainly wouldn't characterize
it that way i know there's border patrol
agents quoted and
a lot of your stories and you speak too
frequently and that's something
we support it's obviously there's a long
tradition of coordinating with
department of homeland security but
uh if we are if our if our policy is is
is
keeping people quiet we are not
successful and it is not our policy uh
to
prevent people from talking and just on
one other topic i wonder if you can
explain a little bit the irs's decision
to delay that the tax filing deadline
by a month of what's the hope of the
impact of this sure i know we've seen
some of those reports uh i don't believe
it's been confirmed or finalized quite
yet
um so uh i will let the irs make their
final decisions and then
if if that is what moves forward we're
happy to speak to it go ahead
thank you jen i just kind of want to
pick up on sharon's questioning over
there
is the white house or dhs instructing
border agents to refuse
ride-along requests from reporters
because that's what a lot of our folks
on the ground are hearing
again i think we've seen watching a
number of the reports you all do a
number of border patrol officials who
are quoted in them who are
up here in them and certainly from the
white house we support that it's
coordinated through the department of
homeland security and
i'd point to them for any additional
questions about the logistics of press
access
i mean our reporters used to be able to
get ride-alongs during the trump
administration and you all came in and
promised to be the most truthful
and transparent administration and you
all you know
oversee the department of homeland
security so if you all wanted to grant
access to the press couldn't you just
tell dhs to do it
again we fully support transparency and
i would encourage you to talk to the
department of homeland security about
any requests you have for press access
or
uh what you're looking to accom
accomplish at the border okay
good question and you know one of the
biggest criticisms of the trump
administration's
remain in mexico policy was that it
overwhelmed all these border towns in
mexico and created
pretty dangerous living conditions for
these migrants and so now you have
the exact same thing happening even
though you all have reversed
rescinded that policy these border towns
are overwhelmed
and the president is saying do not come
so
how is the situation on the ground in
mexico
any different well the situation on the
ground is certainly challenging in part
because we inherited a dismantled system
that wasn't prepared for
processing asylum requests that had
left in place the remaining mexico
program where
people were in a camp that was did not
have the conditions that we felt
popping up well i think what i'm
conveying to you is that we are
less than 60 days about 60 days in uh we
are
working to uh to repair what has been
an unprepared and dismantled system it's
going to take some time
our policy is that we're obviously going
to um
continue to
make sure we're working through our laws
and the border is not open
but we also as you know have um have
changed our policy to approach it in a
more humane way and keep kids safe
and that requires putting in place more
effective and efficient processing at
the border
it's going to take some time we're
working through it every day we have
new steps and new improvements we're
taking to make the system more efficient
and effective
limit or a cap to the number of
unaccompanied minors that are going to
be allowed into the us
a limit or a cap so should we send some
kids who are 10 back at a certain point
is that what they're asking me
i'm i'm not setting the policy here i'm
just asking you what the biden
administration's policy is is there a
limit
to the number of children that will be
allowed in i mean the numbers we're
hearing now 565
on average every day i i'm just curious
what the
what the end game is here how many
ultimately would be allowed in well i
think
we're where we are is we're focused on
some of the very specific
numbers so uh when we came into office
there existed about 13 000 permanent
beds in hhs or
permanent and influx shelter system
facilities
uh during the last administration
thousands of these beds
approximately half were taken offline
due to covid staffing was also reduced
to put it on par
with the new reduced capacity uh this
was sufficient for the
prior administration this is how we got
here because they were expelling
children
in addition to families and single
adults we decided as you all know
that we will be more humane about how we
approach this
there wasn't operational capacity built
the prior administration also did not
consider that there were other
mitigation efforts like
masking improve ventilation cohorting
and other measures that would contain
the spread
of covid there's now revised cdc
guidance which means there's greater
capacity in these facilities where we
can expedite children
expedite getting children into them
there are we are taking steps to ensure
that when
kids come to the border we look and see
if they have a phone number in their
pocket so we can call the family member
and get them to those
family members as quickly as possible
these are the steps uh that we're taking
at this point in time
our policy continues to be we're not
going to send a 10 year old back across
the border that was the policy of the
last administration
that's not our policy here go ahead is
the if unintentionally in your
commitment to keep these young
these children under 17 or 17 understate
if unintentionally is the us government
incentivizing parents to send their
children across the border alone because
that is their best chance
to enter and stay in the united states
well that certainly you've heard the
president say in this interview that he
conducted that he uh is encouraging
people not to come now is not the time
to come
this is not a safe journey for people to
take of any age
and he believes as he talked about last
night that
no parent is looking and just trying to
make a bet
on whether their kid can kind of make it
this is a very
difficult and treacherous journey most
of these kids are fleeing
very challenging circumstances and his
view is that there's a number of steps
we need to take and steps that he hopes
he can work with democrats and
republicans on
so that's his goal how's that message
communicated to that we heard him
obviously in the interview how is that
message being communicated by the us
government to those
thousands perhaps tens of thousands who
are already in the midst of this
dangerous journey that they're making
the border right now
and they are not receiving that message
the thousands of children or the
thousands of families
children's families adults all of them
all the in between that our teams from
telemundo and other reporters on the
ground are meeting
well we convey with every official that
speaks el amiorcas uh secretary allen
yorkis did an interview just yesterday
uh we've heard you've heard roberta
jacobson speak to this and a range of
officials beyond them
who are speaking directly with countries
working in partnership with them
speaking directly through channels that
are in the region that now is not the
time to come
the border is not open this is a
treacherous journey the vast majority
of people will be certainly sent back uh
on their journey and that's the message
we're sending
i guess it seems maybe it's a mixed
message that's received right now but
initially alejandra mayorka said don't
come now right and then we heard from
the president saying don't come the u.s
is in the process of setting up this
system
so that in your own home country you can
apply for asylum
yeah so how do you
it appears to be a mixed message or it's
received as a mixed message which is
don't come now come later and others
don't come at all
well i think this is a no doubt a
complicated circumstance and
what we are trying to do is address this
in an effective and
humane manner and uh that requires
putting in place additional policies and
measures you referenced one of them
which is
reinstituting the uh the cam program
which it would allow kids to
apply uh from their home country that is
certainly a positive an option
we are hoping that can be happened soon
i don't have exact timeline for you but
if we
uh we would like to put that back in
place it was a program that was already
in place and was ended
in 2017. so that's an example we want to
build
uh on beyond that so we can have
programs where
it ensures that kids are not taking this
difficult journey that they have other
choices and other options
but i was also and this will take some
more time but we're going to keep seeing
these cycles which we've seen this is
not the first cycle
2014 2018 these numbers have been
increasing since april of 2020 of last
year
unless we work together democrats and
republicans to address the root causes
there have been policies and bills the
president worked with then
with now senator with senator lindsey
graham as an example on a
on a bill to try to give more funding to
address the root causes in these
countries
if we don't take those steps now we're
going to keep being on these cycles
every year year after year one last
question from the interview last night
we talked about the topic of governor of
new york andrew cuomo
i guess my question is why did president
biden feel the need to weigh
in to say that if the claims of these
women were confirmed that the governor
would likely be prosecuted
well the president respects the role of
law enforcement
and the justice system as we often state
from here and
see is often stated he was asked a
specific question about what should
happen in the if the investigation
confirms the claims of the women um and
he
answered that question this podium
previous democratic administrations have
said we're not going to weigh in not
going to put our finger on anything that
has to do
with the justice department or their he
was not saying this is going to happen
obviously the process is going to hap is
going to play out there's an
ongoing investigation that should be
swift it should be thorough
and and obviously it will determine uh
what the outcome is here and he
certainly respects that
okay thank you gentlemen go ahead this
one a couple of questions so on the
atlanta shootings
do you see some need for the white house
and the administration to
create perhaps a point person to address
anti-asian violence even though these
the shooting hasn't necessarily been
linked it is a concern that the
president has raised
is there some move afoot like that well
well first i would say that it's
important to note that um
you know the president as i as i we've
put out a few a few updates today but
just to reiterate
um he was briefed overnight he obviously
talked to the attorney general and the
fbi director
this morning and we're continuing to
monitor the situation as you touched on
uh local and federal law enforcement are
still determining a motive they
had their own press conference this
morning that doesn't
change the fact that this news was
horrific and broadly speaking there has
been an
increase as you have noted and we have
all seen in
attacks on in crimes uh and uh hate
crimes as well and other circumstances
against asian americans and that's why
he raised this
in his uh address when he delivered in
his prime time address
on thursday night he did sign an
executive order and actually there are
ongoing processes
including from the department of justice
where they're doing
listening sessions now hhs will start
those soon
he's he's he signed that executive order
uh within the early part of his
administration
and he's also asked susan rice and
cedric richmond to do listening sessions
as well
so that we can hear from the community
and determine how that should impact
policies moving forward
uh broadly speaking as you know there's
also an ongoing review
of domestic violent extremism that is
wide-ranging that is a hundred day
review that will take a look at a range
of issues and that will also
be a longer-term strategic comprehensive
look
at um how that impacts our society and
this will certainly be a part of that i
just wanted to follow up on nerd
and north korea sort of talks that are
happening uh with the chinese
what are you looking for from china on
the on the in terms of the response to
north korea the
u.s military expects north korea to
start testing resumed testing of icbms
what would that mean for your review of
those policies
i don't think we're going to get ahead
of their testing
if they are testing if they decide to
test i will say that
uh part of our strategy as it relates to
uh the denuclearization of north korea
is of course to lead with diplomacy
uh and engagement with uh partners in
the regions even some where we have at
times adversarial relationships
is a key part of that strategy and so uh
the secretary of state the secretary of
defense
were also just recently in south korea a
meeting with also with the japanese
uh they are key partners as we discuss
security in the region and certainly
uh the the threats from north korea are
part of that and
obviously that will be part of the
discussion with the chinese but uh
our the strategy is to coordinate and
discuss with partners in the region
uh uh so that we can determine what the
path forward looks like and then finally
on mexico since we're talking about the
border but
mexico and canada are also looking for
doses of vaccines uh there are some
reporting out
saying that you those would be at the
top of the list can you confirm those
reports can you say
you know there's a growing demand i keep
asking this question
you know it's like there's so much
demand out there
and the level of vaccination is so
disparate
in the advanced economies and in
developing countries but also in
neighboring countries like canada
and mexico can you can you just say what
your strategy is to get
vaccines out to the rest of the world so
that there aren't
you know increases in variance and and
all the other negative you know
consequences of not getting the pandemic
under control
sure well andrea our our first strategy
is of course to ensure the
american people are vaccinated and 1400
people
a day are still dying in the united
states of america and so we are still
in the midst of fighting a war against
the pandemic right here
now we have vaccinated more people in
this country
because of access because of supply
because of
operational capacity than virtually any
other country in the world
and we also want to be the president
wants to be
uh we all want to be uh contributing
members of the global community and
getting the pandemic under control
uh any decision we make about requests
and we are we have them from around the
world as you well know in our tracking
will ensure that we're able to still
quickly vaccinate the american people as
that remains our top priority
we have received requests from both
mexico and canada
and are considering those requests
carefully but i don't have any update
for you on
whether they will be granted and a
timeline for that go ahead
uh following up on darlene's question
about the russians were clearly very
upset
what did the president actually mean
when he answered yes or something like
that
to is president putin a killer
was he talking literally or was he
talking metaphorically
i don't have anything more for you to
provide analysis on that um but i can
say
extremely upset about it he also he also
repeated a story that he told in his own
book about a conversation he had with
president putin and
as was the k as was evident in the
readout we provided of the call the
president had with president putin
he does not hold back on his concerns
about
what we see as malign and problematic
actions uh whether it is
engagement in the 2020 intervention in
the 2020
election interference a report obviously
released
just yesterday uh their involvement in
the poisoning of alexey navalny
ongoing reviews that are related to uh
bounties on troops
uh and of course the solar winds hack so
we are he's not going to hold back in
his uh direct communications
nor is he going to hold back publicly
and we have still
found ways to work together on areas
where
we uh have mutual interest including the
extension of new start by five years
so um that's diplomacy in action
there good go ahead what's our one more
yeah if you don't
from moving from russia to uh china so
while secretary's blinking in austin are
out in asia
isn't there's another elephant in the
room which would be
the growing talk about china having
designs on taiwan
is the does the u.s publicly committed
to defending taiwan
come what may uh i don't think i have
anything new on our policy as it relates
to taiwan for you today
um obviously there are a range of topics
including taiwan that will be discussed
in these conversations in anchorage that
are happening over the next
two days if i'm getting the time frame
correct and i'm sure the secretary of
state and the national security advisor
will
come out and engage with the press when
that when those meetings conclude
go ahead thanks jen uh that's that dni
report
there's an assessment in there that
moscow will continue to try to influence
u.s elections
and it said the reason is that the
kremlin has concluded
that it's a manageable risk and so i'm
wondering i know
i anticipate that you're cooking up some
sanctions down the road we've gotta
review it whatnot and we've heard some
sharp language from the president
but it seems like moscow has concluded
that they can handle that
and so what how do we keep them from
interviewing the third consecutive
presidential
election well first
our the president's relationship and
this administration's relationship with
the russians will be very different from
what we've seen over the last four years
and we've already seen
evidence of that from his first phone
call with president putin
president biden has been clear that the
united states will also respond to a
number of destabilizing
russian actions and as you know and as
we've already talked about
we have requested new or declassified
intelligence community assessments in
four such areas and plan to respond to
each of them
in the coming weeks those are ongoing um
you know i would say that the russians
have intervened or attempted to
intervene
in elections for many years i mean long
before 2016
uh and uh we uh you know certainly are
very eyes wide open about that and fully
aware of that
uh but we are uh they're going to pay a
price as the president conveyed
last night we are not going to look the
other way as we saw a bit over the last
four years
and uh we will continue to uh press them
on their actions
there's some language in that report it
said proxies for president putin
have have undergone a disinformation
camp or underwent a disinformation
campaign
in particular alleging or pushing out
disinformation of corrupt
of corruption of president biden and
also the report specifically mentions
his son
so what is his reaction to uh
putin and his proxies going after him
personally that was not our first
awareness of that
um i think we all saw that play out uh
in public
uh so the president felt it was
important to release the unclassified
version of this report which as you know
was the assessment was done under the
last administration
uh it is the evidence of the hard work
of the men and women in the civil
service who
keep government functioning but it's
important for people in this country
members of congress other countries to
understand
what their actions are and if we want
our adversaries
uh our adversaries like russia are
attempting to divide us
and one of our strategies is to
transparently expose their tactics
so that the world is aware of them so
that's why we released this report
go ahead on the president's interview
he said on taxes that anybody making
more than 400 000 will see a small
to a significant tax increase
uh to clarify did he mean individuals or
households because it wasn't very clear
and secretary allen i think has referred
to households before
families yeah
um and i didn't get to ask the secretary
but
um i know the white house is committed
to trying to open schools five days a
week how many hours a day would that
include is it are you pushing for full
school days five days a week
yep go ahead
oh go ahead good i'm very drawn to the
green i'm sorry
go ahead and the red the red and the
green you know go ahead
the president said in the oval office he
didn't i'm going back to atlanta and
then i want to ask you another question
on the border but uh the president said
in the oval office he didn't want to
make a connection on the motivation
in atlanta but to broaden it out why
does the president
think attacks on asian americans are
increasing in this country
why does he think that's happening well
he he wanted to be very clear because
there's an ongoing fbi investigation
right and he didn't want to attribute
motive there are law enforcement
authorities who do that
um and it's important to note when uh
when the
uh when the investigation is concluded
or not so that was a
bar he was attempt working to respect
there um
you know i think there's no question
that some of the damaging rhetoric
that we saw during the prior
administration
uh blaming uh you know calling covid uh
you know the wuhan virus or other things
um
led to um you know um perceptions of the
asian-american community that are
inaccurate
unfair uh have uh raised um
you know threatening uh uh has elevated
threats against
uh asian americans and we're seeing that
around the country that's why even
before
the events of horrific events of last
night he felt it was important to
raise this issue elevate it during his
first prime time address
why he signed the executive order
earlier
in his presidency and he will continue
to look for ways to
elevate and talk about this issue moving
forward said yesterday he does not have
plans to visit the border
why not because his focus is on
action and taking actions and moving
forward policies
to ensure we are expediting uh
the processing at the border that we are
opening more facilities that we are
putting in place policies that will move
kids more quickly through
the border patrol facilities more
quickly into
safe and secure homes and that's where
his focus is
he doesn't want to get a first-hand look
down there himself and talk to officials
there how is he getting
he talks to plenty of officials and he
also has received a briefing
with photos with uh and directly from
his team who went and visited
the border and went to a range of
facilities frequently be getting updates
on some of the numbers of
uh people who are being taken in and how
frequently is he talking to officials
that are down there
who are getting that first hand look
well he's getting updates i mean
sometimes it's a part of his pdb
uh he gets updates regularly i mean
several times a week it's an issue that
is front and center for him and
certainly he's asking questions uh in a
range of meetings
with senior officials about progress
that's made about
uh systems that he thinks should be
unstuck about looking for more creative
ideas to help ensure
these kids are treated uh they are put
into safe they are treated
put put into safe places and that the
work is expedited at the border
go ahead jen there's a report out that
the president
personally opposes the reopening of
the homestead detention center in
florida does he have a personal view on
it or is he just uh
differing to hhs hhs is in charge of
looking at facilities and
what is which ones are going to be the
most appropriate and effective ones to
reopen and he certainly defers to them
on decisions that are made on that front
because this has been a controversial
and i don't need to tell you this yes
facility in the past
so he doesn't have a particular position
on it it's still on the table that i
could reopen
there hasn't been a decision hhs would
be the ones making a decision i don't
have anything more about the president's
personal point of view about
specific facilities just on uh the
president's remarks on taxes
last night um two things one
when might we expect a major push in
this and two what does small to
significant
mean it depends on how much money you
make
are you a billionaire then you may pay
more in taxes than someone making
you know family making 425. um you know
there's going to be a range in any
uh tax proposal uh he talked about this
on the campaign trail
and uh his uh he talked about it uh
during this interview last night in part
because
it's on his mind about how to ensure
people are paying their fair share
and that we are looking for revenue
funds to continue to build back better
but
i don't have a timeline for you and when
you'll hear more it's just uh something
that he
has long had a commitment to and i
expect in the coming months or
sooner than that you'll hear more about
his next stages of his agenda but
uh this is certainly part of what's on
his mind and what he would like to work
with congress on
go ahead yeah in the abc interview
the president said the democracy is
having a hard time functioning
can you clarify was he just talking
there about the senate
and the filibuster is or is it a broader
concern
he was asked in that frame um and asked
in the frame of how to get
work done um how to move forward the
agenda for the american people and
the president's an optimist he is a
person who believes
that there is a lot of opportunity for
democrats and republicans
to work together that there is a history
of support for
some of his major priorities whether
it's infrastructure uh or
um uh you know solving cancer
doing doing taking taking steps to to
help cure cancer
uh to uh increasing america's
competitiveness there's another bill
that's
being considered on that front that
there's a lot of areas where
even immigration there's a long history
of democrats and republicans working
together on that policy
so he's a believer that there is an
opportunity to work together
but what he's seen is democracy having a
hard time functioning and
in part that is why were there no
republicans who supported
a piece of legislation that the almost
80 percent of the american people
supported that doesn't seem like it's
democracy functioning there
and so he was answering a question that
was uh about the filibuster but more
broadly speaking about what he's seeing
and one other thing because we're
required to have an irish question today
sure uh
in talking to the t-shuck did he make
any commitment
as far as uh once presidential travel
resumes
uh to a trip there i know in his heart
he would really like to go and i'm going
to go on that trip um
so uh i'm not aware of any specific
timeline for travel or anything along
those lines that was made i'm happy to
check for you
he has raised several times that next
year st patrick's day will look much
different than this year as i know he
did during the meeting so
you know everybody get get some sleep
and rest before before a year from now
we've got plenty of time go ahead jeff
said he's briefed with photos has he
asked for or been shown these photos of
inside
the facilities where some of the
children being helped for three days
yes that was part of the briefing he
received when his team came back
he approves of what he saw i didn't look
too uncomfortable i know the media
are trying to get in there to get their
own pictures he it looks okay to him i
certainly did not say that
uh this is the the border patrol
facilities are not facilities made for
children
uh he is uh committed to expediting
uh the processing at the border one of
the reasons he wanted a briefing
from people who have been in there so he
can see himself what it looks like
and he has redoubled he was already
committed before this his efforts to
ensure there's a we limit it uh at two
to
three days um and that we move kids as
quickly as possible into
these shelter facilities where they can
have access to health
to medical experts to educational
experts to
legal advice and even beyond that
you know one of the practical steps that
he's really pushed the team on is
how many of these kids when they come
across the border have a phone number in
their pocket
and can we embed hhs and orr in the
system
in the process so they can call that
number and see if that can be a vetted
family member
to get these kids connected to quickly
so uh he
wanted all the specific details he got
that briefing which i talked about a bit
in here about a week and a half or two
weeks ago i can't remember the timeline
and since then we've put in place a
number of steps to expedite the process
to look for additional facilities
and to look for ways to um to uh improve
that very challenging situation at the
border
uh let me just go to making sure i get
everyone linda go ahead thanks jen
um one for me and then one from i'm the
pool reporter so i have okay another
outlet
so my question actually it was for
secretary cardona but i'll ask you
sure is the bible administration
concerned about the number of families
choosing alternatives to public
education
pandemic and does the administration
have a plan to encourage them to return
to public school
it's a great question i wish you'd asked
him that question i'm happy to talk to
him about it i know he had a very
limited amount of time today i was just
excited to get him here
um look you know i know that this past
year's not looked
for school as a mother myself my
daughter did not start kindergarten this
year
and i know a lot of people we know a lot
of people had to make different choices
and but i can talk to him more about
what the plans are to encourage people
to get back into the public school
system and obviously that's an important
and vital part of
communities across the country did you
have a second question
the other question from another outlet
so after today's meeting with irish
t-shock are there other international
meetings
on the president's agenda in coming
weeks there's
there certainly will be uh i don't have
any to preview for you today
but uh engaging uh he's had a number
already of
remote engagements with his counterparts
around the world
uh foreign policy is his one of his
first loves and so
i certainly uh can convey to you that he
will have more of those in the weeks
ahead and
as they're scheduled and finalized we'll
share those details with you go ahead in
the
back
got the 19 vaccines what does the
president say to americans who
have ethical concerns about taking some
of those vaccines that they
that might violate their conscience
give me a little more information why
would i violate that the jonathan
johnson
one ah that one has ties to uh a
connection to abortion derived cell
lines
um so some people um that would violate
their conscience taking that with so the
president would say
what to that he would say i know the
pope has spoken to the safety and
efficacy of
all three vaccines and the american
people
these these vaccines have been validated
by health and medical experts they're
trying to save people's lives
keep people safe and return our country
to normal on
schools billions are going on
are going out to try to get them to
reopen now if come fall
if schools are still unopened would the
administration find that unacceptable
we certainly expect schools to be open
in the fall
go on airports yep uh
tsa reporting big numbers going through
airports is the administration worried
that
the copa 19 response team's message is
just not getting through to people
they're telling people
don't travel don't travel don't travel
and people are plowing through the
airports
well we certainly have to reiterate and
our health and medical team
are doing the same it's not a political
message it's a message from our doctors
that's
just conveying the fact that the
guidelines have not changed in terms of
uh limiting commercial travel if people
are not vaccinated
um especially you know there is there
are great risks to travel we've seen
that play out they've spoken to this
frequently our health and medical
experts so
we'll just have to keep reiterating that
message we understand it's hard
people want to see their family members
people want to go see their friends
but we are fighting through this
pandemic people are still dying
across the country and we will we'll
keep at reminding people of that go
ahead in the back
press conference next week with the
president any idea how it's going to be
assembled
will it be in here somewhere else i
don't think it will be in here because
we would it would be very limited
numbers in here
uh we are working to figure out where we
can do it in the white house to
ensure we have a greater number of
people uh who can attend and we will do
that in a very transparent
uh manner uh so we're we're we're
looking we're sight looking at this
point in time and we'll have
more updates for you soon go ahead in
the back first question from
a colleague is president biden going to
call uh president the president of
ukraine
zavansky in the near future do you have
any update or
any other potential engagements in the
near future
i don't have any previews for you on uh
foreign leader calls at this point
typically we
preview those maybe the day before
typically
but i'm sure he will have some in the
near future but i don't have
any specific ones to preview for you
today on the vaccine
the president said yesterday that the us
is in talks with several countries about
sharing
a vaccine in the past you criticized
russia and china for so-called
vaccine diplomacy and you suggested that
it should be done through
international projects or institutions
so do you exclude
sharing vaccine on a bilateral basis
i think our criticism was in response to
questions about whether we were
concerned about how
vaccines were being used in some ways by
russia and china in ways that they've
used
aid and and international assistance
where there are no strings attached and
sometimes it allows countries to hold
themselves to lower standards on
human rights on freedom of press freedom
of speech
and we've seen that play out as we know
in recent years
so that certainly would be something
that is of concern to us
we have not yet provided vaccine doses
to
any country we are we of course have a
range of requests and a number of
requests and
uh we will consider those carefully but
since we have not
done that yet i don't really have
anything more to update you on
yeah um you talked about the team that
went to the border yes greet the
president they've
shown him photographs yeah i think there
was a request at some point to have
members of that team come back come to
the briefing room and do everything
so where does that stand and since there
are photos
from that team why not release those
since with the previous lines of
questioning you have said
go to the border patrol or go to dhs for
the access questions
i'm happy to invite them to the briefing
room and talk to them about the photos
and will that team return to the border
or some other configuration of
staff members will they be making
periodic trips down there to assess
conditions or
was this one and done i expect we'll
have additional uh
trips to the border but i don't have one
to preview for you today
thank you everyone happy st
patrick's day
oh i i wasn't 400 i was saying that if
you're a billionaire
you're going to pay more in taxes than
somebody making 425 over 400
over 400. i was just as an example oh
okay yeah okay sorry i wasn't trying to
change the threshold yeah we were just
like oh no
no no i should have used something more
you know 572.
thank you
you